how does it go about my name if for you
or bad welcome back to some more cry of
fear holy [ __ ] are we gonna move down
there oh [ __ ] oh you forgot about hello
ladies how you doing alright see you
later
hey Randall Gandalf what alright I'm
gonna go in here back up
I have lantern with me this time back
off back off by the power of lantern Bam
Bam Bam
hey I kill your friend how does that
make you feel you're angry show me
I beg whoa whoa whoa I was just kidding
just kidding just look in my health look
at my health my health is amazing give
it a serene
it's refills like by using nobody's [ __ ]
what is this infamous revolver huh what
is it I want that [ __ ] I'm reloading
that getting too dark too dark to see
ladies woo lady girl lady gaga's triage
with ok hello there we go
come here there we go that's what you
get your little shooters [ __ ] you
oh no no where I'm on omarama know where
I am I know where I'm at that's when I
say goodbye to Lady Gaga I don't have
anything [ __ ] me
I'm so screwed I'm so screwed there we
go there we go there we go there we go
don't come here don't come here don't
come here don't come here don't my Uncle
Matt don't come home for me don't come
back don't come back don't come here
don't come here ah she's polite thank
you there you go there you
no no no no we don't have to argue I
love you
okay yes una dos tres and you're dead
that's just how it is that's how life
works in video games okay anyone power
generator you wanna [ __ ] with me too huh
no you don't know you don't he's a [ __ ]
all right
more sorry are you kidding me how many
[ __ ] serines can you have how
whatever what happened to the P of you
like it's whatever its frames around it
it's okay I got this I think this might
be actually with the last episode which
is not good for me because there will be
more locks down here there you are see
you shut up Marv lock shut up shut your
mouth oh no oh no this is a problem all
right we'll do this man of steinbeck
merlok style fam
Baga there we go there we go you're not
so tough now are you polish [ __ ] I only
got my punching powers
I don't like punching powers not a big
fan of punching powers there's another
marelok god damn it
come here my Lanka smack that all on the
floor smack that give me some more smack
whoo you good low stop punching me stop
licking me whatever you want hey Marla
casa volunteer fat man there we go
should be proud of yourself correct
nipple
there we go there we go [ __ ] how many
friends do you have quite the popular
merlok aren't you there we go
punch you I punch you punch you slap you
there we go there we go there we go no
don't kill me
I just need you just need to one more
punch I think we have una problema yes
in your ass inserting your ITA's and the
problem is because I didn't pick up the
I can pick up a song I guess we have to
but what should I drop I don't want to
drop the lantern this is okay I get it
we used to serene that's what we do
alright I see in a couple of minute and
then went on I'm so shocked I didn't
know you weren't gonna be fine it would
mean that why did I go all right we are
back and I think we have to
[Music]
yeah
bakka me ha don Allah give me my stamina
back while I hope this was so close I
feel like the ring girl right now this
is like the ringing girls Semele
secretly whatever
I can't do that
you are a dolphin you were born to do
this Simon they were [ __ ] born to do
this
Lily are a dolphin right now do they
want me to swim I can't hold my breath
or not there's another dead end all
right isn't it great all right any more
Lux here huh huh
there we go bring it bring it all of you
not afraid of Mon frère
actually quite
inventories I hate it's not the chainsaw
guy oh wait a second it's not a key Wow
there we go there we go okay I love you
I hate don't love you anymore I changed
my mind about things I think it's time
for you to move out and find a new
boyfriend okay we're not together I get
it I get it I'm in the water how you
like water is that your only although he
likes water
hey hey hey chill chill chill chill I'm
a dolphin look whoa
dolphin no he denied my dolphin eyes why
would you do knowing that's the problem
when they deny your dolphin Ness I
always wanted to be doctor
my parents were all this against it all
the ways they were like Peter you can
never be a dolphin I'm like mom please I
just want to do this one thing when I'm
an adult fan I put a fan on my back and
I started practicing this sounds like oh
no I'm dropping you garnish because I
love nightstick too much [ __ ] off you
little [ __ ] I'm a dolphin that's how I
roll [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] with
dolphins dolphins part for you in your
but we like it
okay there we go now we go to the other
place not a problem not a problem
I don't really have to take these breaks
when I breathe it's more like I am a
dolphin and I do what I want that's how
I roll [ __ ] dolphin gets all the
ladies by the way all the ladies in the
house yeah I don't know what does
alright now we go over here
no wait yes I should not have hesitated
God show me your Simon Simon the dolphin
powers I'm in the sound and I mean what
am i well done Simon
Simon I mean what alright the door is
now unlocked language that was easy
hmm totally it's all leather in two
seconds oh it's such a nice weather
outside today I think I'll just take a
stroll outside and see what we can find
wait you gotta check all the corridors
in this game cuz you don't want to miss
any valuable stuff you know all right
vot father was a little vibe the sewers
of silliness if you remember afraid of
monsters it was kind of similar we rode
a boat and then oh look at this night
mom I need it hello so I was at my mom
sounds like he's got some instructor you
know butter not can you ride a car but
have you done to police bail the
interiors is destroyed I bet police bill
did it well done police be
Oh No what is this this is no you're not
supposed to shoot me you're not I have a
tongue I have a lantern he shot himself
am i that ugly really really no not
possible they shoot themselves when you
come up close hey I know I know I'm not
the handsomest guy in the world but he's
like Callaham hello oh god damn it no
that's not funny
Keller sounds look at my ugliness I got
a new secret weapon going here holy [ __ ]
it's works every time works every time
lets me just go in the back door that
won't work
I mean Lantern is gonna scar over here
yes worked it worked a senorita's
and known models alright let's see what
we can find in dark room of darkness at
won't loudness I am saving here for [ __ ]
so long my sense of its own nay nay
you know just know just don't do it
don't do it can I close the door why did
who gave you those knifes woman girl
little girl
Oh gave you those you're not supposed to
play with us no no no no she she she
slap you slap you only because I love
you
only cause I love you and you need to
learn you're dead now don't care don't
care never really cared anymore
hey nice backyard
let's see if we can find whoa spam
shooter with more spiders
all right I have Serena's at least and
revolver ammo because I totally have the
revolver so that's cool it's there come
on
I don't need ammo for a gun that I don't
have thank you very much it's cool it's
cool how you doing bad whatever you are
where are you been there you are aren't
you a bed aren't you a fine bed slap you
there you go
dolphins are way superior than BAM see
now I don't even know why you're trying
anymore oh why are you doing what are
you doing kill yourself of ugliness
there we go all right I think I'm gonna
beautiful face you look like a square
all right like and favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe to come about today
and don't miss the last episode I guess
it's the next time cuz I got the feeling
story's bad wrapped up anyway
[Music]
39,000 husband
I know my dad